you know it's after lunch the rooms dark
I get it
hello welcome thank you everyone for
coming my name is Dave
and I'm talk today about c-sharp and I'm
gonna talk to you about lowering because
I like lowering I like c-sharp I like to
know what the compiler is doing I find
it interesting I do work for Microsoft
but I don't work on the compiler I work
pretty closely with the compiler team
and the Roselyn team but this is mainly
just interest and good practices and
things that I think can help you be a
better developer so the first question
is what is lowering has anyone heard the
term before I can't see any but there is
a really big light there so maybe um
okay so that's good because I'm gonna
explain what it is so if you'd heard of
it you'd be bored let's pretend that
we're all in a language design meeting
and we're going to discuss in our
fictional language that looks a lot like
c-sharp how we take a for each loop and
how we compile it to intermediate
language right il which is what dotnet
code combustor and so we're all
discussing you know strategies how we're
gonna do this what's your favorite I
Alex touch instruction what's mine and
in the back corner there's someone who I
once a he's lazy but he likes efficiency
and he likes to do the least work
possible
his name is lowering and he says you
know why are we discussing this we don't
need a for each statement we just tell
our users if you want to write a for
each well you can just write a for loop
and they do the same thing this code is
equivalent so fine he's pretty
belligerent so we we accept his idea and
we start discussing how we're gonna
compile a for loop to io instead and of
course after a few minutes up ups the
hand well we don't really need a for
loop because everyone knows a for loop
is just a fancy way of writing a while
loop and this does the same thing so
it's less work for us okay fine
and of course you can guess what happens
a few minutes later up pops the hands
a while loop is really just a convenient
way of using a go-to statement so we
don't need any of this right and after a
few more minutes of talking actually we
get to I out now this is the only il in
this talk because I'm not talking about
il mainly because I have no idea what it
does I mean it runs my code somehow but
the only thing that I well not the only
thing I understand but I do know what
this means
so here we can see a bunch of labels
right there line numbers or memory
addresses you can think of them as
labels and this line says BLTs - il 24
this is branch if less then and - 24 so
if we think about our code if something
is less than something else and there's
stacks involved in this and we have
registers and whatever we don't worry
that but if that means less than
something else go to the start and
that's exactly what I'll say right it's
pretty clear thing is this is all il can
do there is no loop construct in il
there is no block construct it's just a
bunch of instructions and a bunch of
branching which is basically go juice so
everything we write in c-sharp has to
eventually get down to this level anyway
so the idea behind lowering is that it's
easier to do as much of that work to get
to this level in c-sharp which is a nice
language than it is to do it all in il I
won't say it's not a nice like which I
don't know so yeah so lowering is we
have the compiler take our code and
convert it to a lower form but of the
same language and there's plenty of
examples of this in c-sharp so hopefully
we all know what link queries are and I
think link queries is one of the most
most well known examples of lowering
even if you didn't know that it was
called lowering because a link query can
be written two ways we can write our
query syntax like this but hopefully
most of you know and I think most people
do that this is equivalent to writing
using the method syntax and in fact in
rosslyn in Visual Studio
with refactoring say convert loop to
link there's two options you convert it
to query syntax or methods syntax so
these are the same things that built the
query syntax gets lowered into this form
you might have heard the term syntactic
sugar so lowering is essentially the
opposite lowering is taking the sugar
away the thing is you know I said it's
everywhere at this code also needs to be
lowered because these are extension
methods the way you write an extension
method is uses static method you mark
the first parameter special in and the
compile lets you kind of pass that first
parameter in but as the thing you're
calling it on but they are also just
normal static methods so this code is
actually equivalent to this right
enumerable dot select is a static method
and instead of calling it on a
collection we pass our collection in and
our collection is the result of nowhere
and then we have lambda expressions
there of course they need to be lowered
as well and conceptually they kind of
get lowered to this you can kind of
think of them as methods so what started
as a query that looked like upside-down
SQL can also be written in this really
fairly standard c-sharp and so if you're
writing a compiler you've got to write
code that converts this normal c-sharp
into IL it's easier for you to convert
the fancy c-sharp into normal see sharp
and then into IL it's it's I mean it's
basic code reuse that we all do right if
you think about the previous example of
for each and for etc if you had a method
called for each that compiled a string
of code be much easy to change that code
to a4 and then call the for method then
have six methods that alright the way
out anyway that's lowering its
absolutely ever actually you're just
gonna switch to visual studio for a
second so this is this is the Roslin
project solution so Roslin is the
c-sharp compiler if you weren't where
and it also includes IDE bits a used to
include a project system which I work on
but doesn't anymore um in the compilers
folder and under c-sharp and in the
actual compiler here there's a folder
called lowering and in here there's not
a lot there's you know ten or so files
this is where all the code lives that
does the lowering and lowering is about
rewriting codes rewriting code so
there's a bunch of folders there you can
see called rewriter every writer then if
we look in the local rewriter folder
this is all of the code that lowers code
it lowers c-sharp in place so these are
the simple ones which and I'll talk
about a few in a minute but if we expand
this folder you can see there are heaps
of files here and there's all sorts of
weird things you wouldn't think about
like if statement you zoom back out is
hopefully future shears no open file now
yeah so this is how we lower in if
saving you kind of wouldn't think that
if statements need to be lowered right
that's pretty low level code it's an if
statement if we scroll down there's a
comment here that says what it is so an
if statement has a condition and a block
but remember in il there's no such thing
as a block so the way we run in if is we
have to invert it and skip them about
next bunch of code so even an if
statement gets lowered essentially into
a go to go to S or everywhere right so
there's all these files it's it's very
prevalent as a few more examples so
something simple like VAR message equals
NDC Oslo var is not a concept that
they're not net runtime knows about it's
just the compiler we know that when we
type var in this case the compiler will
insert a string well that's lowering
right it has to lower it to code that
says string message equals embassy else
load the compiler also uses lowering to
optimize your code so if you wrote this
code the compiler sees that these two
strings are literals that can't change
and it sees that you're using the plus
operator and it knows how to do that at
compile time so these two lines of code
actually lower to the exact same thing
they both just say string message equals
NDC Osler if we have our bits of our
string coming from somewhere else then
things get a bit different so if these
were constants the
same thing would apply and all three of
these lines of codes could be the same
but if their variables it still gets
lowered it gets lowered into using the
string concatenated because it's faster
than using the plus operator so there's
a tiny bit of optimization that happens
during compilation kind of before
compilation but by lowering even
something as simple as declaring a
decimal a decimal is not an intrinsic
type in dotnet so this actually when it
gets compiled would say decimal message
and I guess it probably shouldn't say
message equals new decimal this is just
a normal constructor there's a
convenience way if you express that
which is the M but when it gets down to
it to compile your code that convenience
was just for you it's not for the
compiler so why do we care while you all
here why are you all here
they don't think too hard about this
nobody leaf it's okay I tell you why I'm
here
I like knowing what happens under the
covers
I like understanding one layer below
where I have to write and I this applies
to life as well I like to know when I
like to notice how the things I'm using
work and I think it helps you use them
better help you utilize them better
my wife had a problem with her onedrive
on her macbook recently and of course I
work for Microsoft so it's my fault and
message popped up she had no idea what
it meant I don't use a Mac I haven't for
a few years I didn't really know what it
meant either but it said there was
something wrong with keychain and I know
enough to know that keychain is where
max keep their passwords so I opened
keychain I found onedrive I deleted it
and we try it again
and it worked I still don't know
anything about max I don't know anything
about onedrive from Mac but by knowing
just one little bit lower I was able to
solve a problem and so I do the same
thing with c-sharp the real concrete
reason to know or one of them is
performance take this line of code yeah
fairly simple string concatenation count
is a number of some kind
this code is perfectly readable to me
but you can see sharp 6 I think we got
interpolated strengths and a lot of
people find these easier to read and
they have a very good point when this
first came out where I was working it
seemed like every pull request that was
open for any reason people would also go
and fix up all these concatenations that
they shouldn't convert them to the new
syntax and that's cool
it's good to clean up code as you go but
every time that happened
I saw a potential performance problem
because interpolated strings like this
compile or lower to string dot format so
string dot format is slower than
concatenation now there's a good reason
for it to be slower and in this case
arguably the first line of code is wrong
because the first line of code won't do
things like thousands separators which
in Australia would be a comma but here
it's not a comma right so except the
allowing for culture and things in your
strings that's a good thing this
probably should have been single format
but it is slower so every time someone
changed code if it had a number in it
great but if it didn't have a number
probably should've stayed within cat
nation and most kind of details
you only know if you know what the
compiler does with your code now the
funny thing with this story is that
since that time C sharp 6 excuse me I
think it was about 6 months ago I
actually went looking for this again to
suggest a change and it turns out that a
community member
because Roslyn is open source actually
fix this problem and now an interpolated
string if it doesn't need culture it
will just lower to string rock and cat
so there's absolutely no reason not to
use them now which is great but it's
still good to know those yeah those ins
and outs all right let's get to the meat
of this talk what is the for each loop
do
so we're gonna be looking at a lot of
code and it's all gonna be on screen I'm
not typing any of this it's too hard to
remember they'll get it wrong and then
someone will criticize me so hopefully
we're gonna have a little bit of an easy
and easy entrance into it it's a bit
like a roller coaster right we're gonna
go start easy have a little bit of a
tough time but then once all right we'll
get back onto an easy path and then
maybe at the end it maybe goes a little
bit too deep we'll deal with that
there's an expression in Australia if
you're feeling sick from a roller
coaster that you go a bit green around
the gills I don't know if that's an
expression in Norway but just in case if
you start to feel like you're maybe not
following along whatever yell out feel
free I'll stop I'll repeat whatever if
you really can't handle what's going on
that's okay you can leave the roller
coaster any time if you put a green card
in I'll know it's because you're feeling
green so you know I'll improve for next
time all right let's talk about a free
slip so I've colored in the body of our
loop here Green that's a coincidence I
swear that's just to say like it's green
like a comment is right ignore this the
compiler you know it does know what's in
your loop but it can't really know right
it doesn't know what console dot write
line does because it would have to go
and decompile console that write line to
find out so the body of the loop is not
important to this discussion so I've
just flagged there so we can ignore it
and because it kind of moves around a
bit so what does the freaks loop look
like well you probably know that for
each works ienumerable so ienumerable
which is up here in the top left has one
method got get a numerator returns in
our numerator ienumerable which is in
the bottom left has three two methods
one property it has a current property
which is the current thing we're looking
at in the way it has a move next method
which goes and gets the next value and
whatever that may mean for that in your
manner and returns true for whether it
succeeded or failed its whether it
succeeded in getting the next one it's
not whether there's another one to get
which is a muddle of work but it's worth
though and then there's a reset method
which nobody has ever called ever
their lives in fact the generated
enumerators that will look at any minute
they just throw an exception great and
then we have onion rule of T which you
know obviously when generics came in we
had generic versions of this so they use
a new operator and they strongly type
things probably in hindsight if the
designers of c-sharp had had their way
again they probably would have you know
generics were didn't break it bake it in
at the start and this little bit of mess
wouldn't exist but in order to solve
this weirdness where there's true eye
enumerators or eye enumerables and you
can implement both forage doesn't
actually care about any of these
interfaces let me demonstrate
so if I type in a for each loop let's go
x equals new my numerator and I go for
VAR y in X so let's make any numerator
so ienumerator
that's sorry this is an ienumerable oops
paint numeral onion rule has one method
called getting you right up so get door
easy beautiful and I can return
well actually like return null if I da
stops o like that because I don't need
to turn thank you very good
so this my numerable is now valid for
for each kind of right there's still a
red squiggle here because it's not
really and what you'll see down the
bottom can't really see but anyway it's
complaining because we need more right
we need not only do we need to get a
numerator method we need that to return
a thing that has the other three things
so this is my numerator and now we will
clearly
right or a class and so this needs a a
current property which covered in one a
move next method which can return true
make a public yeah sure
to 200 that better cool and then we
needed a public void reset which does
nothing
so this compiles right there's no errors
in Meyer list this now compiles I've not
used any interfaces I don't even do any
enumeration and in fact am I still
returning now yeah this is just gonna
throw a null reference exception right
but the compiler doesn't care all for
each actually cares about is that you
follow this this pattern right you
follow this pattern doesn't matter about
the name so this is sometimes called
duck typing where if it looks like a
duck and it sounds like a duck we assume
it's a duck I believe the more
technically correct or perhaps just not
as funny term is pattern based so this
is forages pattern based so that's an
interesting thing to know it means you
don't need to implement ienumerable it
can make things easier so knowing all of
these things how do we actually write a
forage look how do we lower a future so
the first thing we do is we create a
scope right so there's some braces
they're very hard to see by the run and
this is just because our loop variable
well in t'aime in this example we don't
want that to leak out you can't use that
after the footage is finished so we have
to put in the scope and then we get our
enumerator and you notice there's no
cast to ienumerable right it doesn't
matter what values is as long as it
satisfies this contract now there is a
asterisk there and it is the compiler
doesn't allow extension methods call
getting numerator but that's purely an
implementation detail that's I mean it's
a decision that was made but that's kind
of
[ __ ] all right they could easily
reverse that decision change a couple
lines of code and it would be done so
the compiler kind of doesn't care what
values is it just is there again a
numerator and if there is greater I'm
going to call it and so by the same
token the type of a doesn't matter
because we don't care what type it is as
long as it satisfies our contract so
I've used var that's like cheating right
like the compiler doesn't really use var
because that needs to be loved anyway so
then we have a try and finally you know
era Hamming is good this is user code
that we're surrounding so we need to be
careful and then we declare a variable
which is in M and that is exactly what I
typed inside my Forex statement nothing
yeah no magic happens to that and then
we have a while loop so a for each
actually gets lowered to a while loop
and then a while it presumably gets
lowered to go to s and so while we can
move next we do inside our while loop
well we get our current value and then
we call the body of our loop whatever it
is and whatever it does pretty simple
and straightforward does anyone think
I've made a mistake on my PowerPoint you
will notice that it's casting to win
twice why is it casting to win twice
good question thank you for asking
so let's pretend we have a little
example off to the side here we have an
object array and we're putting objects
into it these objects happen to be int
and we're calling a method which takes
an object array and it helps for this
example if you imagine there's two
different people
right one person is creating the array
in calling the method and the other
person was writing the method and they
don't talk to each other so we have our
method which takes an object array and
then it has a loop in it that says for
image for each int in my array now if
you say that in English it sounds like
you're saying go through the array and
find the ins but we can see from the
code on the left that's not what happens
there's no checking here because the
lowered code is just blindly casting so
if you were to run this with something
other than it's in your object array it
would just throw an invalid cast
exception it would blow up and possibly
you've had this happen to you in code
it's not that uncommon that if something
that's not quite of the right type gets
in there you get a cast error so that's
real cool
that kind of makes sense but it kind of
explains one cast right I decided that I
want hints I didn't I can't dictate what
comes out of the current property in
this array so there has to be at least
one cast to get from the type in my
collection to what I've said I'm going
to assume is in my collection but so
what's with the second cast the second
cast is a little harder to explain
because it's kind of transparent but
strictly speaking to put those into that
object array we had to cast them to
object first so that's kind of where the
second cast comes from there's one for
the type of thing in your collection and
one for the type of thing you're
iterating now these are probably very
often the same thing but there are
reasons and examples where they're not
so let's complicate this example a
little bit and this is very terse
because I'm shoving it in the corner but
let's pretend we have three classes we
have a person class and then we have a
customer and an employee
and there could be relationships here
like one could inherit from the other or
they all could inherit from each other
or two good in here one that's kind of
unknown right but for this example let's
just pretend so if we construct an array
of people and put employees in that make
sense employees are people and as long
as there's a conversion from employee to
people of a person available that'll
work
and then where where the person writing
the method well we're getting an array
of people and we want to pull out
customers and that makes sense because
customers are people too good slogan so
as long as there's a conversion
available from person to customer our
code makes sense and in fact person a
who's writing this top three lines of
code could supply a custom it was a
caste to do this conversion person B
could supply their custom explicit casts
a one from employee to person and one
from person to customer and all of this
code will work because the two castes
would be employed a person person to
customer and each of those hops works
and makes sense
if we didn't have two castes though we'd
be going employee to customer and nobody
has provided that relationship right
these two people haven't talked so the
two castes are four obscure situations
like this but that's the type of stuff
you're going to do when you're on the
language committee which is why I'm not
I just read their code and try to
explain it afterwards and then he now
finally we have disposed we call this
Bo's that's fairly easy now this code is
not exactly what the compiler does
there's some liberties here in order to
represent it and the disposed one is a
good example we don't know the type of e
in this slide because I have only you
know certain keywords available to me
the compiler does know the type of e so
when it compiles this code and it does
the lowering it knows if e is disposable
and if it's not it just doesn't output
this line of code easier for me to
representing with your step
so that's a forage and if you go and
write a Forex loop right now and you
look in your dll's and you decompile
your il you will see not this because
this is a c-sharp for 4h a c-sharp 5 and
Beyond for each looks a bit different
watch the while so in c-sharp 5 they
made a breaking change to how for each
loops are compiled and this is like it's
pretty rare that they make a breaking
change like that and the reason is that
in c-sharp for we got link and we got
lambdas and everyone started using them
a lot it was at 3.5 anyway when link
came along everyone started using
lambdas a lot and there was a common
problem that lots of people kept running
into where the loops stopped doing what
they thought they should do and to fix
this problem
this was the fix so to understand why we
need to talk about what lambdas do so
lambis this is a very simple definition
of a lambda we're defining an action
takes a string parameter it has a
consult the right line as its body and
then we call our lambda so this gets
lowered of course and like I said
earlier you kind of conceptually think
it gets lowered like this we write out a
method we call that method but this is
actually a problem and this is a problem
or a potential problem for memory usage
because the compiler doesn't know what
the body of the lambda does like it
didn't know what the body of the loop
does this could cause the whole Class C
to have to live on in memory forever and
this can be a big problem if you're you
know if your class in this case is a
Windows forms form then it could have a
lot of resources that it's holding
lovely sound so in order to avoid this
the compiler creates a class creates a
helper class the helper class gets our
method we assign our action to point to
that method and then we call it cool
except this is a problem every time we
crawl our lambda we're now creating a
new instance of a class so in order to
prevent memory issues we're now creating
more stuff in RAM it's kind of silly so
what the compiler actually does is this
this is where we have our first little
dip because this starts to look
confusing right bear with me
so a helper class gets a static
read-only instance so it's a singleton
right there's only one of them around
all the time and the helper class gets
our pointer to our action so again
static there's only one of them when we
call our lambda or when we define our
limiter we check if we've initialized
this method of ours and if we haven't we
point it to the method and then we call
it so this means will now get one helper
class and it doesn't matter how much we
call this lambda there's no more memory
hit right there's an initial overhead
but there's no more so whenever people
say be careful of lambdas they allocate
this is what they mean they create
instances of these helper classes and
the helper classes you know they can be
one per lambda they can be based on the
the compiler has some smarts to you know
sometimes combine things together but
there's a lot of little quirks to this
so this is sort of something to watch
out for and the problem with foreach
loops only occurs when you capture
something in a lambda and when you
capture something in a lambda it goes
back to the previous way of doing it
anyway
for reasons that hopefully will become
clear so we're gonna ignore this for now
just to make life simpler we're gonna
ignore this singleton pattern and we're
going to assume that our lambda defined
like this gets lowered to this so we
have a helper class a pointer to a
method and we call a method
cool so the problem comes when we
capture variables so if we define a
string y equals world and we we use it
in our lambda but we're not passing it
into our lambda right this is it what
we're capturing Y this is where our
problem start to manifest that caused
them to change from C sharp four to five
so what this looks like on the right
hand side sorry for my body changing is
we get a public property field you know
helper class and instead of the local
the Y being a local variable we're now
modifying that field every reference to
Y that would be on this left hand side
actually get changed gets changed to be
a reference to Y or no helper so that's
not a big deal right one you field on a
class but what happens when we change Y
after we define our lambda does this
output hello world a hello fish anyone
no one's brave enough hello fish and the
reason is that every reference to Y I
guess change to a point where field so
we're setting our field Y to fish and
then when we call this method well it's
just using whatever the current value
the field is so this is a little you
know quirk of lambdas that people sort
of get used to very quickly when they
start to use them when you capture
fields and it's a positive thing right
it's what you want to happen you want to
capture the parameter of the variable Y
not the value of the variable if you
want to be value you pass it in but so
when you introduce this into loops
things get a little bit unexpected so if
we change our loop a little bit to get a
lambda in there we now have a loop
through our values like we did before
but instead of just writing out the
value we're going to add a lambda to a
collection that will write out the value
when it's called
so this is kind of like poor-man's tasks
so M is not passed into a lambda it's
captured so what happens when we lower
this we create our helper we assign our
loop variable and then we add our action
so what's going to happen when we run
this we're constantly reassigning the
same field so if this loop went from 1
through 5 instead of outputting 1 2 3 4
5 when we execute these tasks it's gonna
wax the output 5 5 5 5 5 and this was
what people were seeing they would write
lint queries against a database and
often what they would do is things like
get a list of customers looped through
the list of customers and then get a
list of products and they would get the
products for the last customer
associated to every customer and it was
really common and you could start to see
it like you could start to see from the
title of the question on Stack Overflow
be like oh I know what this is and
fortunately the workaround was pretty
simple but it affected enough people
that such changes so the c-sharp 5
change simply move that inside so now we
get a new helper every time we're
setting a different field easy but you
can also see now where that link oh the
lambda methods and allocations can start
to add up too because we're getting a
new instance created every time we loop
through this collection any questions on
any of that before I continue did
everyone following if you're falling
asleep it's fine I don't want just put a
green anymore call it even
well before we leave captures is one
more quirk to be aware of as a perf trap
so I've added to the lambda here is Ed
because I'm really inventive with my
variable names but this is a field so
what happens when we capture a field
well we can't just add a new field
called Zed onto our helper class because
it's not local anymore so what happens
is that we actually had a field to store
the the reference to the class said
comes from this kind of makes sense if
you think about this said here if you
imagine that as this dot said we're
really capturing this that is you know
an implementation detail so as far as
memory traps go we're now back to the
situation where if you have a lambda it
can keep the whole class that's coming
from in memory forever so again this is
easy to work around so for this problem
and for the loop problem if anyone's
still using the C sharp for compiler the
the solution is you just capture the
value yourself in a local and then you
won't have this problem but this this
trap still exists and it actually has to
exist because again if you think about
it you want your lambda to reference the
current value of Zed whenever it's
called now being a class level field
right this could be changed in another
method it could be changed from
background thread could be changed by
three threads at once you know the
compiler can't rewrite all of your code
so this is the only way for it to work
it's just a potential trap so that's the
simple case for four inches I'm glad
that you're all come along with me
that's good gets a little bit more
interesting now because there's also
something called iterative methods and
so this is the yield return statement
hopefully you're familiar with it this
is a very simple use case we simply do
yield return one two three four five and
what happens is when we run this loop
the first time through this loop it's
gonna return a 1 output a 1 the second
time through this loop it skips the
first line of code and it comes down to
the second line of code conceptually
obviously it doesn't actually skip code
right because you can't do that can you
well let's work out how it does it so
our for each loop is unchanged largely
I've written it more simply with the
using statement but it's the same thing
we call get a numerator we have
next so already we can see one
interesting thing or one positive thing
I'll get in Smith is called once that's
good to know
when we think about performance so we
can we call that get a numerator method
on on the thing it returns immediately
again its method has been rewritten and
of course we have another helper class
this one's a bit more complicated those
us on the next slide and we're passing
minus 2 in to the constructor this is
kind of important remember it for later
so what does our class look like well it
implements all of the interfaces just in
case I guess I numerator of everything
but it does double duty as an I
enumerate tour and an ienumerable ok
that's interesting we have three fields
a state a current and a thread ID now
state kind of gives the game away here
it's going to be a state machine ok
hopefully we know what state machines
are it's pretty simple one so we'll be
right we have to implement our
interfaces so we have current properties
that return the current field and we
have a constructor and the constructor
takes in initial State remember it was
minus 2 it stores the initial state it
stores the thread that is currently
running so it stores the thread ID for
the thread that constructed this right
the thing that called get it's ok not
get a numerator but get ins and we have
a disposed method that doesn't do any
and I guess there's a reset method that
doesn't do anything either because it's
by the interface so I get a numerator
call looks like this starting to get a
bit more complicated I know it's alright
we'll go through it line by line
so if state is -2 that's our initial
state so it is you know a little run
through here and we're still on the same
thread then we set state to 0
everything's fine and our result is this
we are our own end
Reiter okay if that's not true we
construct a new helper but with the
initial state of zero so at the end of
this method we're going to have an
enumerator whose state is zero
the thread stuff is because this get int
method again it's just sitting there on
a class anything could be calling it
from any thread you could call it six
times in a row before you actually
iterate over the results so this
enumerator is smart and it will reuse
itself when it can but if it can't you
get a new one again for performance
reasons these are all interesting things
yes good question what happens if the
current thread changes before the
assignment happens that's a very good
question
I suspect that so this is a
representation of the code that is
written this is not really the code
right so I probably should explain this
what I mean this in more detail the
c-sharp compiler when it lowers code it
doesn't literally output c-sharp back to
itself okay the c-sharp compiler goes
through various stages and most
compilers they parse your code and they
posit into something called a tree a
syntax tree and when the lowering
happens it's actually at the tree level
so we've worked out what the code means
syntactically and when we output the
lowered version it's actually by just
modifying the tree so it can do some
tricky things like have this comparison
be the very first thing that happens or
something like that but in this case if
state was -2 and thread ID changed in
here then potentially this could be a
problem but since it's set state to 0
the next call through to this would fail
this check and you get in you a
numerator anyway so I think in practice
it
okay possibly two at exactly the same
time mark was a problem that's something
interesting maybe look into that later
anyway so at the end of the end result
of this method sorry did I see a hand go
look at the end result of this method we
have an enumerator state is zero we're
all happy we're ready to go and so this
is what our move next method looks like
I mean obviously this would be under
there right and so this is our state
machine and other than the fact that it
uses funny numbers that negative numbers
for some reason it's reasonably simple
to understand when our state is zero how
current is one we said our state to 1
when our case is 1 our courage to reach
our state to do so this is a state
machine that just jumps through our
different yield return statements now it
also sets state to minus 1 and what that
means is I'm busy getting the next value
ok because again the green is user code
the fact that I said yield return 1 it
doesn't know that I could have said
you'll return going call a really slow
web service so that this line of code
could take ages to run so the state
machine just controls that and then we
get to the end at Carney's five sets
eight to five when state is five we set
our set to minus one and we just return
false but there's no more values so all
this is doing is it's kind of like
unrolling the loop and that makes sense
because if you look at our original
yield return it's an unrolled loop right
if you want to return six things in
order you can just return six things in
order and five minutes per and so we
have these states for our state machine
and we have - to get enumerate hasn't
been called so we haven't started yet -
one we're getting the next value 0 were
ready to go but no one started and iam
writing yet and then 1 / 4 which is
really 1 to n because it could be any
number where we're just doing nothing
current is set we have a value we're
waiting for the next move next call it
may or may not happen and then 5 or in
plus one we're finished there's no more
data to get so that's relatively simple
but that's for a simple series of your
returns you can of course get more
complicated so what happens how do you
unroll a loop if your loop contains a
loop how do you are right and and
obviously again I've put in 1 and 10
those could be any numbers how do you
unroll a loop if you don't know how big
it is so there's some changes to our
helper when we do this so the first
thing is we get a new field we're now
wrapping someone else's enumerator we
get a dispose method that actually does
something it's got some states again and
we now have a minus 3 that's new welcome
to the party and it calls finally and
finally calls the wrappers dispose I
don't know why dispose doesn't call
dispose and then finally could call
dispose that feels like more saying to
me but anyway this is how they do so
we're wrapping in a numerator okay I
move next method gets a bit more
complicated but that's for the next
slide oh we're doing that we can see is
we're catching errors and just making
sure we clean up and then pass the
Arizona now this is where our
rollercoasters going off a cliff you
ready things get kind of there's lots of
states here so let's talk to it from the
top
initially our state is 0 right all of
the -2 threading stuff is all the same
when we are ready to run state is 0 so
we're going to set our state to minus 1
now that minus 1 used to be we're
getting the next value that's not what
it means anymore now it means we're
getting the enumerator that's going to
give us an x value because remember we
don't know what our value is we get our
enumerator which again this is just
whatever was typed in compiler does
nothing to it doesn't know what it does
I thought that has to be an iron your
own ienumerable then we set our site to
minus 3 okay so minus 3 is now a new
intermediate state where we've got
something
to give us a value we haven't got the
value yet and don't forget this is in
our move next method so our job is to
get the next value so we come down to
here and while we're in move next we
have we wrapped something so we just
passed that move nets go on if we if it
can move next we can move next we get
the current value a state is one we're
all good if he can't move next we're
finished so call our finally and a
dispose clear the wrapped a numeral and
return false there's no more values if
anything comes in here so not the
initial state well if the state isn't
one then something's gone wrong
right c11 is set here means we had a
value we never know whether there's
another value right move next gets the
next value it doesn't tell you whether
there's anything left to get so we never
know that but if we see if we were
successful last time then we still
remain successful and we try again so we
said say 2 minus 3 if we've run out of
values yet return false does this make
sense does anyone have any questions
this kind of gets a bit hairy so we've
got a new state now right minus three is
running but getting the next value minus
one is also running but it's getting the
other a numerator minus two is the same
we're doing our thread stuff zero is the
same we're waiting but now we've only
got one state we are suspended current
is ready for you to use and we're
waiting for a move next call but it's
also finished because we don't know when
it's finished so that's going we're so
let's bring it all together and let's
talk about why it's worth maybe in my
opinion knowing about this stuff this
code snippet is completely arbitrary
obviously and quite convoluted but it's
also relatively short there's two
methods there's you know eight sort of
real lines of code and
if you were asked about the performance
of this method well there's nothing
that's obviously happening that's very
bad right we're looping over some stuff
there's an ordering okay so swatting can
take time fine but everything else we're
just riding for the console but if you
had to think about the performance of
this method knowing what the compiler
does to it it should have showed you a
different picture right you can kind of
see behind the curtains so we can see we
have a loop okay we know that our loop
is going to get rewritten to a while
that's not a big deal we've got a
parameter being passed in to get int
that's okay we're not closing over
everything fine against well that's an
iterator method so we know we're going
to get a helper class and we know that
if threading is an issue or if this
method is called by lots of things we
could end up with lots of instances of
this helper class so that's interesting
that could be a potential problem we
have a simple yield return so we're
going to have a at least one case of our
state machine is going to be a simple
setting current cool that's fine but
then we have another yield return which
is inside a loop so we're going to wrap
an enumerator here so that's interesting
because our enumerator uses min which is
a field and it uses max which is a
parameter so our class that we've
created to help this now needs a
reference to the class that this whole
bunch of code is in so it could hold
that reference for a while and again
there could be hundreds of instances of
this class and we've also going to
lambda method in there so that's going
to be another helper class that lambda
method also uses the field so that's
going to have another reference to the
same class and the parameter and so this
simple bit of code you can kind of sort
of see it expand in your mind is
actually quite complicated and if the
Wi-Fi is behaving I can show you exactly
how complicated by clicking this link
sure go Chrome so this website that is
currently loading is called sharp lab
and sharp lab is an awesome website it
worked it's used very frequently by the
compiler team it's not official
Microsoft it's just written by a guy
from New Zealand who's a really nice guy
any one of the things that can do is
show you what your code looks like so
here on the left is the code from the
sample I had and here on the right is
what it looks like when it's decompiled
now I've been talking about lowering and
what the compiler does before it outputs
the c-sharp this is D compilation which
is slightly different this is code that
has been compiled all the way to Al and
then decompile back again to C sharp so
there's some minor differences but not
many and if we scroll down I mean the
first thing you can sort of see is just
how much code there is here right
there's a lot of stuff going on for a
relatively simple example here's our
case state machine here with
constructing new instances of classes
and things he's our actual don't know
feeling like helper class hope there's
our reset method yes not even
Plattsburgh
he's our actual code that does the
enumeration so here's our while loop and
he's out getting its method so all of
this code is running for everything
every time you run the code of the lift
so when you kind of think about
performance you think about complexity
you can start to see where if you know
what the compiler is doing you have a
new perspective on the complexity of
some bits of your code
so if you have enjoyed this stripped
down into the depths there's a couple of
places you can go to get more things get
more info
so the Roslyn source code is awesome
I'll actually show it in a second give
some more examples your favorite
decompiler is a really good way to do
this again not quite exactly the same
but most of them have options to turn
off you have to turn off optimization in
the D compiler because it will try to so
if you open up il spy which is watch up
lab users in generally and UD compiled
that code it actually would come out
looking pretty much the same as what you
wrote because it detects all of these
patterns that compiler outputs and it
reverses them assuming that's what you
want to see but you can turn them off
and if you turn off all of the
optimizations
that's what sharp love is doing then you
get to see the real code or at least the
equivalent of the aisle and then sharp
lab I really like sharp lab I've made a
couple of contributions to it just to
make it a bit nicer to using things like
that make it well not nice to use to
make it decompile even more because I
want to see the guts it's really cool it
can also run code there's a mouse cursor
somewhere there is so you can also run
code you can see the assembler that's
outputted you can see the il it's got
it's it's fantastic and if you click
this drop-down you can pick any of the
feature branches of rosin so if you want
to see what some of the compiler work
that's still going on will do you can
switch to a branch so records write
records is something they're thinking
about for C sharp 9 it's not in the
compiler yet but if you switch sharp lab
to that branch it will compile your code
with that so you could run code using
you know a preview essentially we don't
even preview just a branch build of
awesome
you can run code and see what it does
the Rozlyn source code though I was
going to show off a couple of things the
cool thing about the rawson source code
is the comments let me find the for each
statement
so this is for each this is the method
that rewrites four inches this is what
we've been talking about and there's a
couple of couple of things so firstly
there's four different rewriters four
for each yes oh this one thank you I
must have done that on the other
instance of vicious tree here
so there's four different ways that it
will compile a for each so a single
dimensional array here has a specific
overload to optimize that case a
multi-dimensional array has a specific
overload to optimize that case so
there's all sorts of optimizations in
here the cool thing is these comments
these comments tell you what they're
going to do tell you what the equivalent
c-sharp they'll be outputting is right
so this is the one we've just been
talking about here's our two castes this
stuff is for acing premium rule which is
new but it's essentially the same
concept there's your dating methods so
this is the stuff you want to start by
looking at looking at the comments
because that's written in c-sharp
if we scroll down to look at the actual
code right here is the line of code that
lowers to our get a numerator call and
you kind of have to really get used to
this before you can read it I mean I
can't really read it it's it's not you
know it's not set up this is two castes
and reading of one property right this
is complicated stuff because this is
modifying the tree this syntax tree you
can kind of see so this is a make
conversion so that's a caste then
there's another make conversion there's
another caste alright we have our where
are we we have the element type right so
one caste is to the element type in the
collection the other type is to the
iteration variable type right the one
that you typed in so you can slowly get
used to this as you explore if you want
to but the comments is really where it's
at and it's all broken down really
nicely if we scroll down we should see
yeah that's not it somewhere in here
here we go so this is a special overload
for collections that you're for reaching
through if they have an indexer because
it can make things slightly faster
doesn't go through ienumerable at all
the compiler still requires you to
implement ienumerable at Royal compile
but when it gets down to the lowering
phase it's like well you know what
oh and bother with that if it can work
out you've got an indexer this will be
faster so there's all sorts of these
optimizations and things if you want to
explore but that's it from me so if
there's any questions you may shout out
otherwise I'll be heading around
otherwise you can go beat everyone else
to the fruit by five minutes
[Applause]